that when women dress that way it's
because they have nothing else to offer
a women dress in a way that shows what
they think they have to offer to society
and if they don't feel and a lot of
women feel very disempowered in our
society and they do feel that they have
nothing else to offer or this is their
primary asset but presumably as a woman
ages because this asset deteriorates so
quickly in terms of its market value
most women who have anything else to
offer switch what they're selling to
like I'm a good mother or I'm a good
Chef or something like that um whereas
uh it's a really negative sign to to an
individual if they're still showing this
and they're like 40 or 30